hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten will heute gibt es einen zeh
leckeren klassiker denn ich mache einen
rhabarberkuchen mit baiser haube bei uns
in der familie ist es sowieso der
klassiker schlechthin der rhabarber
saison und es wird auch immer ausgenutzt
also von ungefähr so april bis august
wird eigentlich fast jeden tag in
rhabarberkuchen gegessen danach darf man
aber nicht mehr essen weil dann die
oxalsäure zu sehr konzentriert ist und
ich zeige euch jetzt die zutaten bevor
der murat mir hinten ganzen rubber weg
ist also für den mürbeteig brauche ich
200 gramm mehl 60 gramm zucker 80 gramm
butter
ich nehme etwas abrieb von der bio
zitrone dann einen halben teelöffel
backpulver 3 1
ich brauche etwas vanille extrakt und
eine prise salz dann brauche ich für die
füllung eben rhabarber ich habe es hier
so ungefähr 750 bis 800 gramm
ich habe hier 150 gramm zucker und hab
da auch schon zwei teelöffel zimt
mitarbeit könnte auch gern weniger oder
mehr nehmen hier sind noch 50 g
speisestärke und für den belag brauche
ich drei mal eiweiß und 150 gramm zucker
denn das wird einen rhabarberkuchen mit
mit rhabarber schicht und pc
das erste was ich jetzt mache ich nehme
den rhabarber und muss den schädel
gewaschen ist nun schon und dann schlage
ich ihn einfach in kleine stücke
da war ich sehr süßlich geld ja
eigentlich rhabarber gemüse aber mal
benutzt sagt die ob spruch den rhabarber
joghurt die schlecker und kabarett ist
lecker aber war kuchen vielleicht habt
ihr so ein lieblingsrezept könnt ihr
einfach in die kommentare schreiben oder
mit direkt zum beispiel rezept schicken
und ich muss nach für euch das wäre doch
eine palette sie da bei dem rhabarber
einfach immer von oben nach unten ab und
ich stehe einfach nur so viel wie eben
runter geht dass man muss dann zu viel
wegnehmen
jetzt gebe ich hier über den rhabarber
noch den zimt zucker da kann nämlich der
rhabarber bisschen die feuchtigkeit
rauslassen also das zieht ein bisschen
wasser und dann gebe ich gleich noch die
stärke mit dazu und während ich den
rührteig ein mürbeteig vorbereite kann
daneben der apa besucher ausziehen
ziehen lassen jetzt einfach kurz stehen
ich gebe jetzt auch die stärke direkt
mit dazu
sally warum die stärke damit es dann
später die feuchtigkeit bindet also wenn
ich jetzt nur den rhabarber mit dem
zucker vermischen lässt daher wie gesagt
das wasser und damit am tag verbraucht
im coupé also wird es wie so eine art
putting dann in und drin
manche kochen sogar vor bedingt das
finde ich überflüssig da ist kann man
sich sparen
man könne auch stadt stärken sagt stopp
nehmen könnten
aha und jetzt habe ich mir hier eine
springform bereits vorbereitet ihr könnt
auch ein bug rahmen nehmen
hier geht es natürlich bisserl einfacher
ich habe jetzt eine springform mit dem
durchmesser 28 zentimeter habe es auch
schon mit butter eingefettet und
vermählt ihr könnt aber auch eine 26
nehmen also bei einer 26 gewitter kuchen
dann hör und bei der 28 eben flacher und
ich mache meinen weg in der
küchenmaschine in mixa ihr könnt ihr
aber auch mit der hand verkneten ganz
schnell es geht auch oder mit knethaken
das geht auch nun gehts halt im mixer
echt viel schneller und da gibt es
einfach alle zutaten rein nacheinander
also alle für den mittag auf die vanille
davon immer nur so kleine tröpfchen alle
zutaten reifen bereit ist kann es also
ich im prinzip auch im olympic aber
eigentlich sagt man das nur berührt
eigen die dann auf einmal verrührt werte
habe ich noch mit dazu gegeben
eigelb und des rezepts finde ich auch
ganz gut weil praktisch das eigelb im
teig hat und das eiweiß dann später oben
auf dem auf der pc masse jetzt noch ein
bisschen zitronenschale abgibt dass ich
fürs aroma da
beim rührteig ist eigentlich so dass man
später um zucker verrührt und anna und
so weiter aber da gibt es eben auch die
abwandlung mit dem all in zeigt dass man
alles zusammen führt aber möglich
eigentlich fast stimme all in
das reicht dann auch schon und dann
könnt ihr den teig direkt in die form
rhein geben
und dann drücke ich dann einfach mit den
händen so ein bisschen fest
der stoff ist gruselig wenn euch das
böse nicht wäre dann könnte auch gerne
die butter mit rein geben und er nimmt
eben ein voll und dann noch die zwei
gelbe mittags
jetzt gebe ich noch ein bisschen vanille
zum rabatt dazu auch wieder nur so ein
paar tröpfchen früher des kurz und es
ist auch die feuchtigkeit ist schon
ausgetreten und durch die stärke wird
sie dann im backofen eben gleich geboten
jetzt könnte man den map pack for help
for backen aber das braucht man
eigentlich gar nicht man kann es auch
direkt jetzt den rabatt aufgeben das
land vor backen und dann eben später den
bc drauf geben hier einfacher bahrain
meine mama de filter sogar immer noch so
ein bisschen sahne mit rein
aber ich finde es braucht man an dass
sie aussprach
es wird dann einfach schön verteilung
bis zum rand ich habe da so ein ganz
kleiner rand hochgezogen zum zentimeter
etwa müsste einfach gucken je nachdem
welche backform ihr wählt dass da eben
da was öffnet austritt und so wird es
jetzt im vorgeheizten backofen erst nach
vorgebacken und zwar bei etwa 190 grad
ober und unterhitze für ungefähr 30
minuten und in der zwischenzeit welchen
kurz aufräumen und dann gleich den
eischnee aufschlagen und denen dann eben
nach 30 minuten mit drauf geben und
fertig backen
also im prinzip ein sehr einfacher co
jetzt bauen einen kuchen im backofen nur
noch etwa fünf minuten und ich kann
jetzt schon mal beginnen das oder diese
pc massa vorzubereiten
es gibt dafür das eiweiß in meine
schlüssel rein dann eine prise salz mit
dazu von geht schnell von erdmann zwei
früheren
jetzt gibt einfach noch den super mit
ein
das ist dann noch mal etwa drei minuten
so verlässt
der nächste bitte
so sieht jetzt der kuchen aus und so
sieht meine wg masse aus also richtig
schön fest jetzt könnte theoretisch mit
dem spritzbeutel zum beispiel auftragen
aber ich habe kein einfaches rezept dazu
mal das jetzt ohne spritzbeutel einfach
direkt auf dem kuchen und verteilen ist
angleichung löffel bzw
ich hatte ganz wichtig dass die b&c
masse wirklich schön fest ist und falls
ihr jetzt mal eine kleine oder größere
menge machen wollt müsst ihr einfach
immer rechnen pro eiweiß braucht die 50
gramm zucker dann hat er den perfekten
besser sodass jetzt schön verteile hier
auch ob es zügig arbeiten
da muss man nochmal in den ofen
da müsste halt so vorsichtig darüber
streichen damit ihr nicht die rhabarber
stück so wie jetzt hier von unten nach
oben holt das macht ja nix
jetzt können wir zum beispiel einfach
mieten müller zu rücken so kleine wieso
kleine fäden ziehen
habt ihr da noch so eine schöne optik
mit drin muss aber nicht sein könnte
glatt streichen wobei ganz glatt kriegt
man das sowieso nicht deswegen lieber
mittelbuch stark ein
und so kommt es jetzt nochmal im
backofen für etwa zehn minuten und dann
lasse ich ihn komplett abkühlen und
zeigt euch dann das endergebnis
mein papa parkuhren ist jetzt abgekühlt
und jetzt werde ich den am rand hier mit
zum teil xaver ablösen
ein bz schön knusprig geworden ich kann
ich aber auch sagen woran das liegt und
zwar muss man beim bc wirklich die den
zucker richtig gut abmessen als auf drei
eier zucker die müssen auch khouzam
haben kommen 50 gramm oder bzw 250 gramm
und insgesamt 150 gramm zucker und bei
mir weiß das problem ich habe meine
digitale waage grad mit weil ich die
noch in einem karton habe und habe
hinten mit der nostalgie waage gehoben
und es war eben genau dieses schlimm
aber nur falls es euch auch mal passiert
dass ihr wisst woran das liegt also
entweder war es dann einfach zu wenig
zucker oder es war zu kurz gebacken
also es hat immer einen grund ansonsten
funktioniert ist nämlich immer super
momentan hat am ratstisch unter den in
der schublade
ganz unten ganz unten
gucken retten effekt genau den hatte
murat mal in die spülmaschine das darf
man aktion steht er nämlich so aus aber
ist schlimm
ich gebe eigentlich immer nur sache in
die spülmaschine dich mit hand wirklich
nicht machen will oder kann alles andere
sowas kann man immer mit der hand
waschen und backformen jetzt im café und
dazu den rhabarberkuchen ich halte jetzt
echt schade dass es nicht schön knusprig
ist nackt in das stimmt hat richtig
lecker
und deshalb schön flach weil ich diese
große form benutzt hat mit 28 cm
durchmesser
ich glaube meine mama nimmt immer eine
kleinere die machen dann höher
aber ich finde auch so richtig gut jetzt
habt ihr hier den mürbeteig und dann die
süß sauren rhabarber stücke und den
füßen dsd und wenn dennoch schön
knusprig stand ist richtig lecker aber
dennoch so gut gell morath ich bin
rhabarberkuchen und wp geht immer weil
es einfach die perfekte kombination ist
den rhabarberkuchen gibt es aber auch
mit zum beispiel vanille quarkcreme und
streuseln den werde ich auch mal machen
denn das ich mag auch alles was streusel
hat aber dieses rezept gibt es jetzt zum
nachlesen auf salehs - blog.de
und wenn ihr das nach macht und mir ein
foto schickt würde ich mich das sehr
darüber freuen
wo hast du noch was zu sagen habe heute
ein mikrofon vergessen aber ich okay
wenn du heute leise tisch ich bin noch
krank er hat die männer griff naja bis
zum nächsten mal